and burn yeah those are big ones yeah i
do it i'm like
studio equipment someone's gonna hit the
lottery they jack those still out for
delivery slices
so it's gonna be like whoa whoa
well yeah should they drop these off
this morning i had no [ __ ] clue oh
listen
talk to them about it man i'm jealous
right now but tell them i'm jealous now
they call those the the
[ __ ] baseball gloves no dog
these are the bodegas i always say that
because he says
the one the one with the black and white
oh yeah see how they have a real big
right look at this you gotta wear them
with certain jeans man
oh you look like you you look like you
ride the short bus
that's a japanese collab chin those are
like huge sakai is huge they're
expensive yeah
yeah um dope ass kick though you gotta
be real
careful what jeans you want i feel like
i need another pair of jordans
yeah i'm feeling like it's coming off
yeah i hate that i'm feeling it yes
nikki
oh your vans right here my vans are
right there and they're going they're
going nowhere
is that like i'm feeling it man you
thinking
more ones i like the one there's these
ones i do like the ones those are
there's these ones that are like uh
travis white and brown
travis oh the mochas the ones i have the
mochas is that what it is
well what is the is that nike signed
backwards on it yeah
uh jordan mochas yeah yeah i got those
yeah those came out
you know you know we got uh uh shoe of
the year the brand
can you guess let me guess someone in
here guess what got shoe of the [ __ ]
year okay hold on wait those are the
ones you like
i like those don't say don't say show of
the year or branded
uh brand like yeah like best don't say
new balance
new balance by a landslide are you
serious isn't that some [ __ ] kawhi
is like such it's not even quite it's
like all the collabs they did all the
shoes they dropped
away all right though and jay loves new
balances so does uh schultz
you know who else loves uh new balance
white mike white
turner it's a certain level it's a
certain demo that [ __ ] with new balance
yeah
i've like i have a grateful dead new
balances i wear a lot but
man dude nike
i told you reebok came to me years ago
and they had a deal like but you gotta
only wear reebok
you said no this ain't happening really
i feel like it makes me physically ill
to just wear reebok i actually can't
even picture you you know i can't do it
you wouldn't even copy iverson no nope i
love nike
uh well i'm only people i know like like
section what is the like the new
balances yes
washington dc they they're big out there
yeah well in new york new balance is
huge baltimore
oh so it's a fascist thing it it started
but now it's big man new balance is big
really what is this weird like if you go
it might be on dope new balance type in
a shoe brand of the year
it might be a complex article but
i don't know i just don't [ __ ] with them
you think pumas i can never wear those
the easy yeah i'm good with the jordan
ones and fours
i like the fours there's these other
travis scott ones that i like they're
blue
i don't know which oh i have the those
are the fives those are fives those are
dope
i got those those are the first scots i
got oh dude those are
north carolina blue yeah right oh yeah
have you seen the friends and family
package yes i've seen their purples
man i wish i was his friend or family
[Music]
put the order in also i got some new
slip-on vans on the way so
that's hippies oh your boy uh
dan danny uh danny no
the the [ __ ] 411 driver he
rode his bike yesterday in vance i
thought of you oh really he didn't blog
you just gonna do this in the vans like
that
he's worth millions of dollars that's
kind of disrespectful
he's modest just saying nike dunk is the
2020 shoe of the year
no he said brandon i know but uh
companies in the world are nike adidas
new balance
um pull up those travis scott
fives yeah those are those are dope i
like those
also do we know how do they gotta be so
hard to get
do you know how easy it is to get vans
there's a reason [ __ ] so easy
well i'm just saying are these the watch
ball
i like those those are stitches don't
get the set i have the i like those
those uh
the blues those blue ones nope that's
what i like
yes those are my favorite colors blue i
got those those are beautiful
you got those damn we shall you and you
got them
yeah we shall well when i try to get
them we shall wear them one day what are
your
sizes i i wear 12 12 i wear 11 11
yeah we could all fit yeah we can all i
can fit all those
oh you can up to 13 yeah well you wear
11 through 13.
well i could obviously fit 11 and 12. 13
is my biggest size
oh got it yeah good playground some
shoes i don't know how those shoes run
do you like because you scored are you
able to get 13s for all of them or do
you have to run
i get 13 yeah if 13. because these 13
and nikes
i got these i got these guavas these are
12s they but they're tight they're a
little tight
i probably should've went 12 and a half
but the ones fit
so perfect and those are 12s i would
probably get a
13 in those travis if you were me yep
are you serious well you can't try mine
on
see if okay yeah that's right let's not
just get the smaller shots yeah do we
know who like make these like
posts like who's the best sneakers like
who do they have come from like legit
like i just sent chin the article
but see new balances they've they've
done all these collabs you don't want
those
i'd wear those those miamis those are
those are dope those are hard
look at those dior but so that's the top
of the list on this one right
yeah but hypebeast is pretty legit but i
thought hypebeast had uh
some articles there's nike right there
those diors were impossible to get i
couldn't call they are
how much you know how much girls run bro
what 12
grand bro 12 grand not doing it dude i
gotta continue
i gotta connect it too and he was like
they're like
dude they're spoken for like what i
couldn't get him they'll come out for
four months i'm hitting you up now he's
like dude they're spoken for him like
[ __ ] what does that mean
right like they already can't like
everyone they're already taken like
there's no they gave them to like
huge celebrities or whatever like drake
like drake gets them first yeah
really yeah and they're not gonna hit
you up they're not giving a comedian
i don't think i'm gonna get addicted i
probably won't get addicted to this shoe
thing
i won't get addicted but uh it is nice
to have like some
pretty cool shoes you know eat some dope
kicks you know but i
i'm not going to get addicted it's not a
bad addiction long as you're spending
within your means i don't think it's
about yeah there you go
don't you spend within your money yeah
within your means don't live above your
means because
that means that you're not being real
with who you are as a person
like one pair a month
you know who got the uh dioras and got
them ruined
billy eilish she got the high tops and
the low tops
[ __ ] yeah she's [ __ ] all over it yeah i
guess her dog had like diarrhea one day
and chat all over her shoes nothing
about the dior's there's a bunch of
fakes out there so i had a uh my girl's
friend was like hey i know brent's in
the shoes
i have these i'm like man how much she
told me like this
i don't know man it's all 300 bucks dog
yeah she's like oh
she was like 600 i'm like even 600 like
you just flip those and make
why something to me you make 10 g's off
that like what yeah
so you gotta be careful man yeah cause
so so the fakes
are you still you're still making money
off the fakes
yeah it just depends it depends there's
a lot of fakies out there like they just
seized an entire shipment off the
[ __ ] border here oh a ton from china
yeah
they sees it like thousands of fake
nikes
and they were selling them for the
actual price yeah but here you know
here's what's tricky
is how did they get a lot of those fakes
come from the same
factories so some of them although
they're not
technically nike they're still produced
by the theme
the same material the same people make
them but they're not
actual you know what i'm saying they
don't come from the nike
like you know what i'm saying like
they're they're the same factory
they're exactly the same but there's
just some slightly off
not even off like they might just be
just not certified because they're not
certified through the nike
but then so nike has to certify all
these oh yeah they have to go through
there's a whole thing
there's a whole thing but but here's
these are easy but here here
here's what's here's what
yeah like my son you know the same the
the woody uh
toy story uh reeboks for christmas yeah
uh
toy story vans they're expensive they
are
super expensive there's some exclusive
vans that get really pricey dog
damn thousands of dollars any of these
the buzz light the peanut butter [ __ ]
those vans old school toy story woody's
ones see that that's 369.
and that's for those that's the lowest
price on stock yeah no the far
left
damn i click on the challenge i had to
go to go to stockx to get those
kendricks so the high oh the
lowest ass is 369. yeah the highest bid
is 90 dollars nobody bidding on that
at a 10 out of 10 though
how about that when i get off stage at
the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son